[Música]
jornada electoral crucial en Estados
Unidos Este martes el país vota en las
elecciones de medio término para renovar
la cámara de representantes un tercio
del senado y 36 gobernadores estatales
los comicios determinarán el resto del
mandato de showbiden conectamos con
Philadelphia y Washington
en Egipto concluyó la tercera jornada de
la Copa 27 hoy fue el último día de la
Cumbre de líderes de alto nivel con la
justicia climática en el centro del
debate el sur global Pide a los estados
del norte un mecanismo de compensación
por daños y pérdidas Tenemos reporte de
nuestra enviada especial a charmershake
y aumenta la preocupación de ciertos
países como Alemania que temen que sus
ciudadanos lgbt que asistan al Mundial
de fútbol de Qatar se han reprimidos por
las autoridades del país anfitrión donde
las prácticas homosexuales están
castigadas con cárcel
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición en Estados Unidos
porque les continuamos informando de
toda la actualidad de la jornada
electoral de hoy Que va a determinar los
dos años restantes de mandato de
showbiden Y es que hoy se decide la
nueva composición del legislativo
concretamente el país elige los
diputados de la cámara de representantes
y un tercio del senado así como 36
gobernadores estatales las últimas
encuestas indicaron que con toda
probabilidad los republicanos van a
arrebatar a los demó la frágil mayoría
que tenían hasta ahora en la cámara baja
Mientras que el senado está más
disputado conectamos ahora con nuestros
periodistas sobre el terreno mamen sala
Buenas tardes encantada de saludarla de
nuevo desde Filadelfia Pensilvania
empecemos por una actualización del
desarrollo de la jornada
soy muy buenas tardes de momento la
jornada está transcurriendo con
normalidad así nos lo ha explicado este
chico que veis detrás de mí que es uno
de los observadores electorales
voluntarios que están velando porque así
sea en estos centros de votación que
veis a mi espalda así que es cierto que
se respira una cierta tensión y nervio
en el ambiente recordemos que son las
primeras elecciones que se celebran
desde el asalto al Capitolio ese enero
del 2021 y pues la verdad como os decía
no hay que destacar incidentes sí que es
verdad que algunos centros de votación
han abierto más tarde porque los
trabajadores electorales han llegado
tarde o en algunos otros los votantes
han tenido que esperar más tiempo de lo
normal porque no había boletas
suficientes pero de momento se
desarrolla todo con normalidad y se
espera que así sea hasta las 8 de la
tarde que cerrarán sus puertas y mamen
Cuáles son los principales candidatos a
los puestos que se están disputando en
Pensilvania uno de los estados péndulos
recordemos que puede decidir la mayoría
en el senado
si desde luego aquí el puesto más
importante es ese escaño del senado pero
también se va a elegir al gobernador del
estado tenemos en el lado demócrata iOS
Zafiro un candidato demócrata que logró
un gran apoyo económico en las primarias
y justo enfrente Estaría dagmastriano
bueno amigo de y apoyado por Donald
Trump Y que además también negó esas
elecciones del 2020 y además forma parte
de grupos extremistas pero como decíamos
aquí es lo más importante es ese escaño
que hay en el senado tenemos al
republicano
se trata de un presentador de televisión
y cirujano que ha apostado por encontrar
por rascar sus votos encontrar sus votos
en los suburbios y en el centro de
Pensilvania y en otro lado estaría el
candidato demócrata John federman que
como sabéis tuvo un derrame cerebral en
mayo su médico ha dicho que
perfectamente puede realizar esta labor
pero aún así ha sido ataque en varias
ocasiones por parte de contrincante él
ha decidido rascar votos en ciudades
pobladas como esta como Pensilvania y
Pittsburgh pero ambos están muy
dependientes de los indecisos que aquí
en Pensilvania son muchos mamen
Muchísimas gracias por el reporte
continuaremos conectando Cristóbal
Vázquez vayamos ahora con ustedes de
Washington DC como avanza y el ambiente
electoral
Pues el ambiente está tenso está tenso
porque ya varias ciudades han requerido
más presencia de la fuerza pública en
los centros de votación y en los centros
que tras el cierre de urnas se usarán
para el conteo de los votos de hecho en
Carolina del Norte se han reportado 16
incidentes de intimidación al votante
interferencia también de reportes de
autoridades electorales de ese estado
dicen que personas en Carlos con
grabadoras pasan muy cerca de los
centros de votación grabando a los
votantes haciendo las filas y
depositando su voto además también se ha
reportado que en los días anteriores
personas con armas estaban esperando al
lado de las urnas de votación del voto
anticipado y esto pues llevó a quejas de
la comunidad en Arizona además también
se están reportando 18 quejas de
intimidación al votante además
precisamente allá en Pensilvania donde
está nuestra colega mamen sala se
reporta autoridades dicen que pues van a
requerir hacer volver a un proceso
electoral que va a demorar un poco más
el conteo de los votos Precisamente en
un estado que determinará el futuro de
El senado en Estados Unidos Cristóbal
Muchísimas gracias por el reporte
estaremos muy pendientes de la evolución
de la situación que nos Comenta
nosotros cambiamos de información porque
como les comentábamos anteriormente
estas elecciones son la razón por la que
el presidente estadounidense Joe biden
Todavía no se ha desplazado a Egipto
donde concluyó hoy la tercera jornada de
la cop 27 y la llamada cumbre de los
líderes con la justicia climática en el
centro del debate los países pobres y en
desarrollo insisten a los Estados ricos
en crear más mecanismos de solidaridad
climática dado que es el sur global
quien sufre las consecuencias más
devastadoras de la crisis Mientras que
el norte es el principal responsable por
otro lado hoy intervino virtualmente en
la Cumbre el presidente ucraniano fue lo
dimmer selensky quien declaró que el
planeta ya no soporta un disparo más
nuestra enviada especial en charmershare
María Clara calle nos destaca los puntos
más relevantes de la jornada de hoy
después de dos días terminó la Cumbre de
los líderes hoy con uno de los discursos
más esperados el de Pakistán su Primer
Ministro muhammad sharif propuso que se
cree un índice global de riesgos
climáticos para que se priorice la
financiación a los países que corren más
riesgos como el suyo que enfrentó las
peores inundaciones de la época reciente
otra de las evidencias de esta
injusticia climática se vive en las
islas Cook el Primer Ministro Mark Brown
aseguró que el 99% de su territorio está
a nivel del mar por lo que casi todo
podría inundarse si los océanos crecen
por eso le hizo un llamado al grupo del
g20 que produce el 80% de las
contaminaciones a que contribuya más y
parte de este grupo es la Unión Europea
quien también se pronunció hoy Charles
el presidente del Consejo europeo y
Úrsula bunder Legends la presidenta de
la comisión europea hablaron en el mismo
sentido por un lado reiterar que ha
utilizado la energía como un arma y por
otro decir que el bloque de los 27 ha
sido un campeón climático ya que aportó
21.000 millones de euros para la
financiación climática en 2021 Y aunque
Úrsula Wonderland utilizó un discurso
más fuerte al hacer un llamado a los
países del Norte global a que cooperen
al final nunca mencionó los daños y las
pérdidas recordemos que la Unión Europea
se opuso en Glasgow a la creación de un
fondo para este hecho Y por último la
ONU propuso una agenda para la
adaptación con más de 30 planes que
Espera que se cumplan antes del 2030
cambiamos de información porque el
presidente Turco receptaip erdogan
mantiene sujeto sobre el ingreso de
Finlandia y Suecia a la otan después de
reunirse hoy en ankara con el nuevo
Primer Ministro sueco ulf christisterson
recordemos que tanto gel sin que como
estocolmon solicitaron entrar a la
alianza atlántica a raíz de la invasión
rusa de Ucrania pero que todos los
estados miembros de la otan deben
aprobar las solicitudes y una de las
condiciones que impone Turquía Suecia es
la deportación de supuestos miembros del
pkk a territorio Turco nuestro
corresponsal en Estambul adrià Rocha nos
amplía
Turquía mantiene sujeto a la entrada de
la otan de Suecia en Finlandia así lo ha
explicado esta misma tarde el presidente
Turco resetta y perdón que ha recibido
en ankara al Primer Ministro seco ulf
christen senerdovana explicado que
Turquía considera que Suecia sobre todo
Suecia pero también Finlandia se han
convertido en Estados en los cuales la
democracia es usada por organizaciones
terroristas para mantener sus personas
erdogan ha dicho que es algo que se
tiene que evitar crisis ha dicho que va
a seguir todos los compromisos
adquiridos con Turquía que fueron
adquiridos el pasado mes de junio en
Madrid en la Cumbre de la otan por la
que a través de la cual se certificó la
entrada de Finlandia y Suecia a el
proceso para entrar definitivamente a la
ota en ese proceso sin embargo aún no ha
terminado Porque todos los estados
miembros de la otan tienen que ratificar
la entrada de un nuevo país a través de
sus parlamentos faltan dos que voten a
favor de la entrada de Finlandia Suecia
la otan son el de Hungría y el de
Turquía Turquía de hecho sigue con este
veto sobre todo por la razón en que
Turquía quiere que se deporten a
supuestos miembros de organizaciones
terroristas sobre todo el pkk ha
considerado terrorista tanto por Turquía
como por la Unión Europea y la cofradía
de fetu lagunen desde Suecia y Finlandia
hacia Turquía Turquía el mes de junio
pasó una lista de 70 alto en torno a 70
personas que Turquía quería deportadas
Solo han sido cuatro y los demás de
momento no la han sido nos espera que lo
hagan por el hecho de que es la sueca la
que tiene que decir caso por caso de
hecho nos espera que el veto Turco sea
retirado hasta finales de primavera del
año que viene incluso entrado el verano
Turquía en junio tiene que celebrar unas
elecciones presidenciales cruciales para
el futuro tanto de erdogan como del país
anatolio varios países como Alemania
buscan garantías para Que catar respete
los derechos de las personas lgbt con
más que visitarán el país para el
mundial de fútbol recordemos que en el
país anfitrión de la competición las
prácticas homosexuales están castigadas
con condenas de prisión
crece la preocupación por la situación
de los Derechos Humanos en Qatar días
antes de la celebración de la copa del
mundo en especial el trato hacia la
comunidad lgbt y comas las
demostraciones de afecto homosexuales
están criminalizadas por el código penal
del país del Golfo árabe con hasta siete
años de prisión
Nancy pisar ministra del interior de
Alemania se pronunció hoy al respecto
nieva Para mí es importante conversar
con Qatar para ver si podemos hacer algo
por la seguridad de los fanáticos
alemanes durante la Copa del Mundo
proteger a las personas que aman a otras
personas de su mismo sexo y quieren
demostrarlo
esta declaraciones se dan luego de una
controversial entrevista de la
televisión pública alemana al embajador
catarí de la copa del mundo jalit salman
en la que escribió lo homosexualidad
como un daño en la mente
a pesar de los comentarios de salmán
Alemania prefiere confiar en el respeto
de Qatar hacia las comunidades sexuales
diversas previamente Nancy pisar habló
con el Primer Ministro katari jalitt
Khalifa quien le dio una garantía de
seguridad
por supuesto tales declaraciones son
terribles y esa es también la razón por
la que estamos trabajando para mejorar
las cosas en Qatar la garantía de
seguridad era muy importante para mí y
me la dio el Primer Ministro y el
ministro del interior el evento
deportivo que comenzará el 20 de
noviembre recibirá poco más de un millón
de turistas una cantidad que representa
casi la mitad de la población total de
Qatar un reto logístico y cultural para
un país que aplica la ley islámica en su
expresión más radical el sunismo
bajavita
colectivos lgbtiq más se concentraron
frente a la sede de la FIFA en zúrich
Suiza para pedirle que cese la
hipocresía asuman la responsabilidad y
ponga los Derechos Humanos por encima de
la codicia
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con nosotros
[Música]